The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So,
thanks for coming today.
This is a key lecture in
the application of Fourier,
you could say.
So convolution is the big word.
And a major application
of convolution
is filtering, signal processing.
So we'll develop
that application.
But it's nothing
but convolution.
So the key idea is
these convolution rules,
where they come from.
And what these new
symbols, that's
the symbol for the
convolution of two functions.
They could be functions here.
Here they're long
vectors of coefficients,
and so these are the rules.
So it's just a little
bit of algebra.
But it just is so central
to all this subject.
Signal processing is certainly
the most important little thing
to know.
That if I multiply
two functions,
so that's where we
started last time.
If I have a function
f with Fourier
coefficients c, and a function
g with coefficients d, then,
oh, wrong.
I convolve the
coefficients, right.
So f has coefficients
c, g has coefficients d.
So if I multiply the functions
I definitely do not just
multiply each c times the d.
I do this convolution operation,
which we have to remember.
That's our main first step is
to remember what that was about.
And then this is
the other direction.
So we didn't see this before.
That I mean, there's always
this fantastic symmetry
between physical space
and frequency space.
And convolution in one is
multiplication in the other.
It's so easy to remember.
If I multiply in one
space, I do a convolution
in the other space.
If I do a convolution
of functions,
I do a multiplication
of coefficients.
So that's the rule to know.
And now if we expand
on it, by sort
of seeing again what it means.
So let me do a quick
repeat of this first step
to remember what this symbol,
convolution symbol, means.
And then another
thing I have to do.
Here, I'm talking about the
infinite case, functions,
and with a whole infinite
sequence of coefficients.
I've got to do the
cyclic case, too.
Which goes with the
discrete transform.
OK, but let's start
with the infinite case
as we did last time.
Maybe, here's something.
Here's a suggestion.
We had f(x).
We started with f(x), as
the sum -- and remember,
to have nice formulas, we're
doing the complex version --
c_k*e^(ikx).
Let me suggest something.
Let me write z for e^(ikx).
So I'm going to just write
that at the sum of c_k*z^k.
So z is e^(ix).
This is like a good
point to make anyway.
When we have this e^(ikx),
it's natural to think of that
as a complex number
on the unit circle.
Right?
That's always the
message, e to the i
real is on the unit circle.
Absolute value one.
And this is great for
periodic functions.
Because if these
functions have period 2pi,
and if we think of our function
as being on the circle,
it obviously has period 2pi.
I mean, the picture says, yes.
If I go 2pi, I come back.
So x is the angle, right?
x is the-- In this picture,
a little bit unusual maybe,
x there would be the angle.
And it's just a little
bit easier to write.
And maybe it even has an
official name, the Z-transform.
How do you like that?
You learn a transform
just, in fourteen seconds.
Z-transform.
It'll make it easier
to multiply by g.
So g is going to be
the sum of d_k*z^k.
So just think of these
as long, well I'm
tempted to say long polynomials.
I mean, very long, because
they can be infinite series.
Infinite negative powers
and positive powers.
But just think of it as a
bunch of powers of z times
a bunch of powers of z.
And if you multiply a
couple of polynomials,
you're doing convolution.
I guess my message is,
you've been doing convolution
since the second grade.
That's the real message.
Here, let me show you.
This is convolution too.
Suppose I have to
multiply a 123 times 456?
OK, so what do you do?
Remember back, it's a long
way back but we can do this.
One, two, three times
four, five, six.
So I multiply the three,
oh there's a little point.
Where that second-grade
teacher's going to panic.
I'm going to write that as 18.
And that's 15, and that's 12.
Sorry about that, yeah.
And 12, 10 and 8, right?
Four, five and six.
So you see the nine
multiplications
that you have to do?
Nine multiplications,
three times three.
OK, right now
imagine those were,
they could have been longer.
But they were finite length
filters, we could say.
And now, what does
convolution do?
Just what you did
in multiplication.
When I add 12, 10 and
6, what am I doing?
I'm putting together the
three times the four,
the two times the five,
and the one times the six.
That's what convolution,
those are the things
that convolution puts together.
So we got an 18, a 27, 28.
13, and 4.
So I guess I'm saying
that, alright, here's
what I really want to say.
I want to say that the
convolution of those,
with these, four, five, six,
is this sequence here-- Oh.
Yeah, that's right.
4, 13, 28.
27, and 18.
If you just look at that.
Where did that 13 come from?
Let's just remember, where
does that 13 come from?
That came from, this was z^0.
This 13 is 13 z to the
first power, right?
We're just checking
all the powers here.
There's 13 z to the first power.
Where do we get a first power?
We get a z^0 times 5z^1.
So that's 5z^1.
And we also have
2z^1, times 4z^0.
Right?
Two times four gave the eight.
So the eight from there
and the five from there
produce that 13.
And that's just what you
did in multiplication.
Right?
So that's multiplication
of two series.
That's not cyclic.
This is definitely
not yet cyclic,
but we'll make it
cyclic in a minute.
This is the infinite one, except
that we had all zeroes beyond.
OK, so that if you, in
non-cyclic convolution like
this, if I have
length m and length n,
then I get length
m+n, maybe m+n-1.
OK, so that's convolution.
Without carrying numbers.
Without doing it right.
OK, so and what does
that correspond to?
Let me just, so you
see it every way.
That corresponds to 1+2z+3z^2,
multiplying 4+5z+6z^2.
And it gave-- That's times.
And it gave this
thing up to 18z^4.
Just, exactly the multiplication
that you've always done.
OK, so that's the idea.
Over on that board I'm
going to put a formula
for this convolution operation.
But my point on this board
is, you've done it always.
When you multiply a
couple of polynomials,
you collect powers.
And that's all convolution
is doing, collecting
each power separately.
OK, let's do it.
So then f(x)g(x) is, when
I multiply that polynomial
or series by that polynomial,
I get some polynomial in, with
coefficients, oh I
was changed to l,
just to have a
different symbol there.
And what was the formula for l?
For h_l?
What is the coefficient of z^l?
If I multiply that by that, do
you remember the story there?
When I multiply that by that
and I looked for the terms that
gave me z^l?
OK, well that means that this
power times this power is going
to be z^l.
So that the index, do you
remember what happened?
It was a lot of different, just
the way-- This h_l is here.
Here's h_2 or something.
I've got to do an addition.
Because a bunch of c's come in
with different d's, and what's
the deal then? c_k
comes in with which d?
This is the magic number there.
What's the subscript that if I
look at the coefficient of z^l,
I look at each of these.
And then I pick out the one of
these that will give me a z^l.
And which one is it?
d_(l-k).
It's that magic quantity
that the eye spots perfectly.
k and l-k, adding to l simply
because z^k z^(l-k) multiplies
to z^l.
Same thing.
Right?
OK, this is, now I'll
use that notation.
This is c convolved
with the d. c
convolved with d is h.
c convolved with d is h.
So this is the l-th component.
c convolved with d is my symbol.
This h is the convolution.
And that's the convolution rule.
It's just whatever
operation you have
to do to get the right answer.
The right answer
when you multiply.
So that one.
Ready for the discrete case?
The finite case?
The case when, you have
power, when z becomes w.
The discrete case.
The cyclic case, sorry.
Maybe emphasize the cyclic
case, meaning it circles around,
is the case when z becomes this
very special z, on the unit
circle that we know as w.
OK, and we have to say,
and of course it's w_N,
I have to tell you in the cyclic
case how long the cycle is.
So this would be a case.
Watch what you do here
to make this cyclic.
OK, I have three inputs,
so N is three here.
Now I'm going to do the cyclic.
So instead of z's, I
should be putting w's.
I will.
Just to emphasize, it's good to
think of it with the w there,
because the w has this special
property that's critical
to everything, OK so now I'm
going to, I think of this
as 1w^0, 2w^1, and 3 w squared.
I'm thinking of the same
multiplication here,
but now w's.
OK, so I'll end up with 18w^4,
and four was the constant
and 13 w's and so on.
All these numbers.
What's the difference?
Ready for the key point?
Now, what's happened
in this cyclic case?
Well, the difference
is what is w^4?
If we're in the cyclic
case, N is three now,
our guys have length
three, our circle
is, w now is 1/3
of the way around.
So that's my w,
here's my w squared.
Here is my one.
But here it is also w cubed.
So w is the same as w^4,
w^2 is the same as w^5.
So, what's the difference?
What can I do now?
If I'm in this discrete
case, then my inputs
are a vector of length N, three.
A vector of length N, three.
And I want to get out to
a vector of length three.
I'm not happy with that
in the cyclic case,
because I'm not happy with w^4.
So now tell me again that last,
when I do the multiplication
and I just do it, there's
no difference except in how
I write the answer.
18w^4 is the same as? w. w^4 is
the same as w, when N is three.
So that 18w^4 cycles
back in, with this 13.
So now if I do the, can
I show you the symbol?
I'll just do a
little circle there.
To say this is now the
cyclic convolution.
Then this isn't the
answer any more.
The answer now for
cyclic convolution,
I only want three numbers.
And if you can tell me what
those three numbers are,
we've got it.
Move those over a little to
make room for the three numbers.
So there's the answer,
the space for the answer.
What do I write in?
How many, what's
the constant term?
It's 31, right.
It's 31.
Where did 31 come from?
It came from, you could say,
cycling that 27w^3 back with
the four.
Because there's no,
w^3 is the same as one.
So I've gone around the circle
when I come around to w^3.
So that 27 and 4
combined into that 31.
And let's see.
So what multiplications
am I doing here?
One times four gives
me the constant.
Two times six, that's two
w's and six w squareds,
that's 12w^3, that's 12.
And then 3 w squareds
and five w's is 15w^3.
But that's the same as 15.
So that's why we get 31.
We got 4, we've got
12 and we've got 15.
OK, now what's the second
component, the w component
of the cyclic convolution?
Tell me what number do I write
in, in that middle position?
How many w's do I have?
31 again.
This 28, this 18 is
coming back by three.
To 13.
You see, I could have
done that multiplication.
So coming back to 31, am
I going to get another 31?
No, what's the w^2 guy?
28.
Yeah.
28, because there's no w
to the fifth to come back.
So 28 uses three
multiplications.
The 31 there used the
four and these two.
This came back over to here.
And this 31 used,
this 18 came back.
I could have put the 18 here.
You know, I could have
lined it up just three.
So I'll write a formula for it.
So that's the answer.
31, 31, 28.
Could I just suggest a
little check on that?
Just to check on the numbers.
I think that if I add up
these numbers, I get six.
And if I add up those
numbers I get 15.
And if I multiply
that, I get 90.
And if I add those
numbers I get 90, right?
So those add to 90.
So I'm just saying the
miracle check is add these,
multiply by the sum of those.
And you get the sum of those.
Why is that?
Somehow seems right, doesn't it?
Because somehow I've taken
all nine products here, and so
when I add all the results,
I'll have the sum of all nine
of these possible products.
So I'll have 6 times 15.
Actually, here's a
good way to look at it.
In doing this, I just set w=1.
I just set w=1 in
the polynomial.
When I set w to one, this
becomes six, this becomes 15
and the answer becomes
90, when w is one.
Yeah.
So that's another way to see.
And actually, this
multiplication,
the second grade
version, had w, well,
I'm almost going to say
w=10, but not quite that.
Because it's written in
the opposite order, right?
If w was ten, this would be one.
Well, anyway, w can't
be ten, it's got
to stay on the unit circle, so.
So somewhere in the non-cyclic
case, it's something like w=10,
or w=1/10, maybe.
Whatever.
OK.
Could you take the
convolution now,
let me give you just
another example.
Do it mentally.
What's the convolution
of [0, 1,  0, 0],
let me make a little longer.
So I take the, first of all,
the non-cyclic convolution
of [0, 0, 1, 0].
OK.
What's the ordinary-- how
long is the answer now?
This is just practice.
How many components
am I going to have
in the ordinary convolution of
those two guys of length four?
I think it's seven.
I think it'll be seven.
Because we'll have here one, we
have no, we have z^0, z^1, z^2,
z^3.
And here we'll have again the
same, it would go up to z^6,
but remember there's a z^0,
so that's why we have seven.
And what will it be?
What will it be?
I guess, actually, this wasn't
a brilliant example, was it?
But let's finish it.
So I'm just multiplying
z by z squared, so
what do you get for an answer?
I think the one shows
up in the z cubed.
Is that right?
Yeah. z to the first power here,
z squared here, z cubed here,
and we always have to remember
everything in Chapter 4 starts
at zero.
Zero, z^0's the first one.
OK, that's not too
great an example,
because what happens if I do
the circular cyclic convolution?
What would be the
cyclic convolution?
Now I'm expecting
four guys only, right?
The cyclic keeps
the same length.
And what would be the answer?
Well, there's nobody to fold
back, so it would be just
[0, 0, 0, 1].
So let me update this a
little bit with a one here.
OK, just to practice.
So suppose I do
that convolution.
Un-cyclic, first.
What do I change here now?
I've now got a z squared
and I've also got a z cubed,
but I only have a
single one there.
Let's make it a little
more interesting.
OK, make it like so.
Alright, z+z^2 is what
we're looking at, z+z^2 is
multiplying z^2+z^3.
And in the long
form, what do I get?
Let me make space, tell
me what numbers to put in.
If I multiply z+z^2 times
z^2+z^3, I get what?
1z^3, how many z^4?
Two of them.
How many z^5?
One, and nobody there.
OK.
And now the cyclic
version would be what?
What's my answer now
for the cyclic version?
Let me take those out.
So the cyclic version would
bring the two back to the zero.
Would bring that
one back so there.
That zero will still be zero.
And I checked that I
haven't missed anything
by adding those up to get
four, and adding this up
to get two times two.
Yeah.
OK, so that's the rule.
And it's a lot cleaner
to see these answers
than to see this formula.
And I need, actually of course,
now mentioning that formula,
I need a cyclic formula.
So can I write above
it the cyclic formula?
What do I get when I'm,
instead of this sum, which
went from k equal minus
infinity to infinity,
in the cyclic case, h_k is just
going to be a sum from zero
to N-1, and there'll be
a c_k, and a d something.
And now this is the cyclic
case, so I guess this makes us,
I think what our situation
now is we understand
the cyclic case from examples.
And now we just have the job of
how do I put it into algebra.
How do I put it into symbols?
What's the point?
c_k d_n, let's say.
But oh no, I'm
looking for h_l, yeah.
So what's the deal?
Here l was k.
That one is the sum of
that one and that one.
So here, l is the
sum of k and n, but.
What's the but?
I mean somehow I've got some
wraparound to do, right?
When I'm doing the cyclic
multiplication and I'm doing
the wraparound because w^N,
the wraparound comes from that,
right?
That's why I never get as high
as N, because when I get to N
I go back to the zeroth power.
OK, so what's the relation
of k and n and l here?
We just need the right
word to express it.
What's the word?
Mod.
So that's the word I'm
looking for. k+n is l.
With wraparound and
wraparound means,
the nice notation that people
use is mod N. Let's practice.
What is two plus two mod seven?
Four.
Two plus two is
four, even in 18.085.
Right, OK.
But two plus two mod three
is, two plus two mod three is?
One.
Everybody sees it?
I'm taking z^2 times z^2,
z^4, but I'm doing with N=3,
so z^3 is one, so that z^4
is really just z to the first
power.
So this is the
little nifty notation
that says make it cyclic.
Bring it back so that l
only has the values here,
zero up to N-1.
And then stops.
OK.
OK, so we'll have more
practice with examples
when we do some filtering.
Have you got that
fundamental-- So we've
talked about this rule
one here. f times g
goes to those coefficients.
And if it's the
cyclic case then I
put a circle around that star.
And I do the wraparound.
But it's just, it's
the Z-transform,
it's polynomials in z
or polynomials in w,
and when it's polynomials in w,
you use that special property
that w^N is one.
Yeah, OK.
Now, I see I've written
another line, there.
That I could convolve functions.
Let me do a couple
more examples.
Couple of examples.
First, before I go
to that line, OK.
So I'm up to this line.
A couple of examples here.
Let's see, what example
would I want to do?
Let's see, OK, I want to do one
example with a delta function.
One example with
a delta function.
the delta vector.
Yeah, let me take the
function g(x) identically one.
OK, constant function.
In this rule.
I want to see what
happens with the rule.
OK, then f(x) g(x) is
the same as f(x), right?
Because this function g(x)
is so simple, it's just one.
Now, what about the coefficient?
So I have the coefficients
of c, what are the Fourier
coefficients, what are the d's?
Ah yes, what are the d's?
So I'm testing my rule on a
really really simple case,
g(x) identically one.
What, you have to
tell me, in order
to check the right
side of the rule
you have to tell me the Fourier
coefficients for that very
special function.
What would be the
Fourier coefficients?
If I expand the function
one in a Fourier series,
what do I see?
I see a one.
Yeah, that's it, I see one.
So what are its coefficients?
d_0, right, is one?
And the other d's
are all zero, right?
So my vector of d, my
vector of d's is a whole lot
of zeroes on the negative side.
A one right there in the center,
and then a lot of zeroes.
And now I want to
convolve that with c.
I'm practicing the
convolution rule
on a case that's so simple
it's confusing, right?
I mean, it's a big mess,
this multiplication.
What do I get out of this?
If d is this vector, if d has
this property that d_0 is one
and others are zero,
all others are zero,
so this is my
little example, what
does this sum boil down to?
Well, I only get
something when l=k, right?
I only got something when
l=k, because then I have d_0
and that's the only
d that's around.
So in this sum,
something happens only
when k and l are the same.
And then what happens?
Then I have a one, I
have c_l, and that's h_l,
so that's all I'm
concluding then.
That this h is the same as c.
I'm sorry, it's so dumb.
My point is that in
convolution, this is
the thing that acts like one.
Because in
multiplication, that's
the thing, that's the
function that acts like one.
That's the function that is one.
So this is the one in-- Oh,
would you allow me to do this?
I'm going to create a
matrix with these d's.
There's another way
to see convolution.
Yeah, there's another
way to see convolution
and discrete convolution.
Maybe the discrete
one's the better.
Yeah can you stand one more
way to write the formula?
One more way to write,
now I'm going to do,
I'm going to do
discrete convolution.
Discrete cyclic.
So how am I going to write it?
I'm going to write it by
a matrix multiplication.
Because you know
that in this course
a matrix was going to show up.
So it's going to be a
matrix multiplication.
So I just have to
tell you the matrix,
so this is going
to be some matrix.
Let me take N to be four.
So then I have, you watch.
So I have four d's, and
the output is the four h's.
And the rule I'm
following is this rule.
Is this, the same old rule
but with the cyclic part.
And now I want to show you the
matrix that'll just do this.
Look, I've put the c's
in the first column.
And then I go, yeah,
here's another.
So it's a cyclic matrix.
So let me finish it up.
It's going to be four by
four, it's going to be cyclic.
So I have a c_0, c_0,
c_0, c_0 on the diagonal.
That's fine, that's
because z to the zero
is multiplying all the d's
and leaving them in place.
And then I have
c_1's, and then I
think I come around
again here for a c_1.
And I have c_2's, see
where see c_3, c_2.
And I come around again,
to a c_2 and a c_2.
And c_3 comes around to
a c_3, a c_3 and a c_3.
Well, can you, I hope you can
see, this is cyclic matrix.
It's only got one, it
starts with a vector c,
and those are on the diagonal
and the diagonals wrap around.
That's the other
word that you often
see when you see the
word cyclic, wraparound.
It's because you
think of a circle.
If you go a second
time around, it's
wrapped around the first time.
OK, just can you look and see
that this is the right formula
for h_0? h_0 is c_0*d_0.
Where does that come from?
Remember, h_0 is the coefficient
of z^0 in the answer.
So it comes from c_0*d_0 to
the zeroth power in the input.
And then why is
there is a c_3*d_1?
Why is there a c_3*d_1, and then
a c_2*d_2 and then a c_1*d_3
all piling up into h_0?
Tell me now, why
is there a c_3*d_1?
Because we're doing mod
four is one way to say it.
Three and one add to four.
Because c_3 is the w cubed
guy, and d_1 is the coefficient
of w^1 and w^3 times w^1
piles back into the constant.
And you see the
pattern of that matrix?
So these matrices
are very important.
So they circle around.
Oh, we've actually met
a matrix of this type,
the first day of 18.085.
What was that matrix?
It was one of our
four great matrices.
And now here it is back again.
Which one was it?
Well, you remember
the letter for it.
Which isn't going to change.
And do you remember
the particular matrix?
Well, everybody does
remember that matrix, right?
Twos were on the diagonal,
minus ones were on the diagonal,
and the diagonal
curve continued.
Minus one was on this diagonal
and that continued and zeroes
was on this diagonal.
So this is cyclic convolution,
the circulant matrix,
cyclic convolution
by c, what's the c
that produces that
convolution matrix?
It's just, it's got--
well there it is.
The first column is it.
Right, right.
And somehow I would say
that that's an even vector.
It's sort of, I
associate it with cosine.
It's an even vector.
Here is the zero term, and
then these are the same,
not to worry about that part.
Do you see that we've
seen that matrix before?
And the cyclic
convolution means you
take its second
differences, of course.
We're taking second differences,
but everything in our world
is cyclic.
So the result, the x_4 is x_0.
So we're taking second
differences -- well,
maybe I should say d -- we're
taking second differences d_i,
2d_i's, minus d_(i-1)
minus d_(i+1).
I don't know if this is--
So there's a minus one,
two, minus one.
And we're cycling around
so that d_0 is d_4.
And d_1 is d_5, and
d_(-1) is d_3, whatever.
OK, I'm just reminding you,
we've seen these before.
OK, so this is another way
to remember the formula.
OK now, can I ask you
a practical question?
A practical question.
Let me bring back this
second grade multiplication.
Well, I have a granddaughter
named Elizabeth,
I'll have to admit
I didn't think
about mentioning Elizabeth.
She's six.
And she delights in sending
me long multiplications.
I mean, really long.
And then every time I
talk to her on the phone,
she says have you
done that one yet?
And I say, I'm working on it.
I've got MATLAB at work.
Because they're ridiculous
and I haven't figured out
how to tell her.
I mean, she just
writes page after page.
Times 100, plus
three, minus seven,
just whatever she things of.
OK, now I need help from
the convolution rule. here,
actually.
So let's suppose that
Elizabeth has given me
a multiplication in
which I have a thousand
digits times a thousand, right.
Which Mathematica is prepared
to do exactly, right?
MATLAB will mess up, but
Mathematica and Maple
and symbolic packages will
do exact computations.
So what would be the right way,
well let may make it 1,024.
1,024 digits times 1,024 digits.
Let's do the cyclic
version first.
Elizabeth doesn't
know about cyclic.
Maybe I could teach her that.
That'll keep her busy while
I'm doing the multiplication.
OK, right.
Only, her older brother
would explain it
to her, that's the trouble.
OK, so how am I going
to do, or how are you
going to do on the
quiz, multiplication
of a 1,024 digits times 1,024?
And I'll make it easy
by making it cyclic,
so I just want 1,024
digits in the answer.
OK.
How would you do it?
Well, before today, you would
have just multiplied, right?
You would have written down
1,024, two lines of 1,024,
done an addition.
And you would have had a
million multiplications to do.
But how would you do it now?
Apart from giving
it to Mathematica.
What's a faster way to do it?
What's a faster way
to do a convolution?
The fast way to do
a convolution is
to use the convolution
rule, go this way.
So take these numbers,
these 1,024 numbers,
in c and these
1,024 numbers in d,
and, well what do I have to do?
I want to use the
convolution rule,
because multiplying is fast.
Now I've got functions.
But I'm in the cyclic case.
So I'm in the cyclic
case, so what should I do?
How can I change this
to be the cyclic case?
This is like f_j g_j.
So multiplication of components
of things in function space
is convolution of coefficients.
So now, this is the cyclic.
So let me make it cyclic.
So again, what's your problem?
The problem is to do this
cyclic multiplication.
What's the idea?
The idea is to transform c back
to f, to transform d back to g.
Do the multiplications,
now I have
only 1,024 multiplications.
Not 1,024 squared.
That's the point.
And if I do this
directly, I've got 1,024
squared multiplications to do.
Much better.
Transform back to
here, do just 1,024--
what's the MATLAB command for
that, when you're multiplying
each component by itself?
It's not the dot
product, notice.
It's not the dot product
because I'm not summing.
Do you know the
MATLAB command, if I
have a sequence of numbers
of numbers, a vector
f of length 1,024, and I
want to get that result?
What's the result?
It's a vector of length 1,024
that takes each f times its g.
But doesn't do any adds.
That's what's there.
What's the MATLAB
command for that?
Dot, yeah.
Dot star, right.
So that dot says
component by component.
OK, so what's the plan here?
I do c's back to f.
By the Fourier matrix. d back
to g, by the Fourier matrix,
then I do a very
quick multiplication.
And then what?
Then I mustn't forget.
That I'm in frequency space,
and what do I have to do?
I've got to get back
into coefficient space.
So I do the inverse transform
of-- Here's the formula, then.
I'm doing the inverse transform
of, so the transform of c
dot star, the transform of d.
To get c, d.
Is that right?
So I took c, and I got
back into the function.
I took d, and got
back to its function,
with the Fourier matrix.
OK, I'm in the Fourier
and now I'm in this space.
I've added up coefficients
to get in this space.
Now I do the dot
star, the fast one.
And then I transform back.
So why is that faster?
Than just doing it?
Because what's the
cost of F times c?
And how am I going to do that?
I'm going to do with the fast
Fourier transform, right.
That's the point.
I can multiply by F, or
by F inverse, faster.
So I have three of
these transforms.
I've got to get two guys
into the other space,
and the answer back out.
So I have sort of
three of these N
log N's but that will
easily beat N squared.
Right?
So if you have a
convolution to do,
and it's possible to do this,
get into the other space
where it's just an element
by element multiplication.
And that would apply
in either direction.
Because the rule goes both ways.
If I have this
convolution to do,
I would find the
coefficients here,
the c's, the coefficients
of d of the g's.
I would do this one
by one multiplication,
and then I have the
Fourier coefficients
of the convolution.
Right, OK?
Do I have a moment?
Well, hardly.
Just, can I write
down what the formula
for a convolution of two
functions would look like?
Sorry, f(x) convolved with g(x).
Let me make it cyclic.
Just to see what
it would look like.
What am I expecting
for that convolution?
I'm expecting a function,
and somehow there's
going to be an integral instead
of a sum, where I had sums,
but now I have integrals.
And here's the point.
I'll have f(t) times g(x-t) dt.
All I'm asking you to look at
is the fact that the way here I
had k, and l-k.
For functions, your eye
sees that right away as a t,
and an (x-t), dt.
These add to the answer.
These add to the result, that x.
That would be the
cyclical one, yeah.
So I could go
zero-- These are all
periodic functions, so all
2pi periods are the same.
The book will do that properly.
OK, we've got the filtering
to discuss on Monday.
You can see that this
convolution stuff just
takes a little new thinking,
but it comes out nicely.